our continuing series a more perfect
union aims to show that what unites us
as Americans is stronger than what
divides us so we showed you video last
week of 16 year old Ayrton little
everybody loved this story this is when
he learned he had been accepted to
Harvard his brother Alex discovered he
got into Stanford a week earlier my
family celebrations like these are very
common at their school every year it
says a hundred percent of graduates get
into college Wow is right Anthony
Omar Villafranca traveled to Breaux
Bridge Louisiana to see how the school
works with students to LAN coveted
college placements at TM Landry college
prep the holiday celebrations started
early one student learned he had been
accepted to Stanford another to Harvard
then Wesleyan yes Dartmouth and brown
ten students accepted to top-tier
schools all in one week my fingers are
shaking just thinking about it gives me
the chills James Dennis is going to Yale
[Applause]
describe that moment when your
classmates are just going nuts is
completely indescribable Kayla Amos
cried when she got accepted to Columbia
but the future business major says she
shares her success the whole team puts
in the work throughout the years to get
that one person to the school so the
whole team feels relief team ladies just
a family that's the way to sum it up the
students are not cookie cutter where
everybody has to do the same thing at
the same time it's a family under the
guidance of Michael and Tracy Landry
they founded the school twelve years ago
when my wife and I started to school
people laughed at us the skepticism is
because tme Landry is a no-frills school
located in an old fabrication shop in a
low-income area near Lafayette people
think of a college prep school and they
think rich kids are these rich kids oh
not by far their parents have made
sacrifices to
send them here we make sacrifices to
make sure that they could stay the
average income is 32 thousand tuition
costs up to six hundred seventy five
dollars a month there are teachers but
no textbooks no homework and no specific
class schedule students from
kindergarten to high school I would find
the Antechinus
help tutor encourage each other to learn
because you're with all these other
people that are always striving towards
greatness just like you are it's almost
like you have no choice but to conform
to it go big or go home if you don't go
big in regards to being the best student
that you possibly can be one day you can
end up still being that kid who goes to
jail
or who dies early because you went out
the wrong way and you went into the
streets it's not about being smart it's
about working very hard he works very
hard Maundy dennis is the mother of
James Dennis she works part-time at the
school to help pay tuition she was there
when James learned he was accepted at
Yale I was grateful I was thankful and I
was proud then why are you crying
because I never thought this was
possible but there is disappointment
this senior received news this month
that he is on a waiting list the
Landry's also sometimes struggle to make
payroll all that makes their payoff even
more rewarding when a student is
accepted into college we have no sports
we don't have homecoming prom
so for me that's like seeing your chow
just win the game
that's my lottery that tells me that
we're changing people we're changing
society we're giving hope with more
admissions decisions coming in the
spring
school expects more celebrations for
education Omar Villafranca CBS this
morning Breaux Bridge Louisiana I love
seeing how the kids celebrate each
other's success I love it too it's tough
to watch though when they don't get hit
I would imagine but nobody's laughing at
the Landry's now it's interesting no
textbooks no homeworks and I like what
she said about it's not about being
smart it's about working hard they're
not working hard being smart is good but
it pays off in spades as you see if you
work really hard they have figured your
secret sauce
they really had nicely done nicely done